let's see what we can do with this thing
I've got two equations now I've got an
initial condition what is this question
posing to us you have a pair of
particles okay and each of their
velocity functions are defined in terms
of their displacement so you know where
it is I can tell you how far how fast
rather it's traveling in on what
direction okay come here going perfect
timing okay so you've got this pair of
particles it tells you even though it
doesn't matter so much in this case they
both moving toward the origin from the
positive side okay so perhaps from the
right-hand side moving to the left
you've got this first particle and they
tell you where it gets really strong so
you get an initial condition and then
here comes the question where should be
be where should it be released from if
you want them to release together and
hit the origin together okay so they've
got two different velocities functions
in the movie different speeds but we
want them to start at the same spot and
eventually get to the origin together
okay it's ironically it's a little bit
like the kind of truck we were looking
at yesterday it's like the star in two
different spots but two different
velocity functions will get them to the
overtaking Lane at the same as in a time
so make sense that's the picture so
you've got two particles here we'll
start with the first one now unlike
yesterday's question where they were
almost no clues or at least the clues in
the question we're very very vague here
I think there's excuse me a bit of a
clear path through oh you poor want to
listen to this one I'd say yeah Oh what
would you like me to do as a first step
if I'm just thinking about the first
particle setting it into no no no are
you yeah using me
okay alright so what I'm gonna need is
to remember and by the way one of the
clues wise hey this is an initial
condition it's a time condition so with
this guy I need to reintroduce t it is
so this remember there's two particles
ominous name this is the derivative with
respect to time of particle A's
displacement ok so I'm considering that
that's what this function is equal to do
add as ref just mention i can take
reciprocal so that i can integrate with
respect to X or I really should say X ok
ok so I'm going to take reciprocals at
turns this guy upside down so I'm going
to get this sweat and now I'm ready to
integrate because that would get me a
relationship between time and
displacement that I could use this on
does that make sense so I'm going to
integrate both sides with respect to X
of a ok that's a very much that's all
right I'm going to get T on the
left-hand side and on the right-hand
side i'll just write the integral first
and they will deal with it so this is 16
plus matt squared with respect to exit a
so what for that are we looking at what
standard or is this this is terry verse
good so i'm going to say we got this
minus site at the front the teeny versed
state of result remember it's gone
fraction at the front right depending on
this this is that a square plus x
squared yes so i'm going to get one over
for tan inverse R it's not good it's ok
with all four and of course because this
is a definite this is indefinite there's
going to your constant comes along for
the ride I know but I have to do this
again so I'm going to do great is my
first constant
no I don't need to i mean in some senses
I never need to do that it just makes
things tidy up the place where I attempt
to use that is where i'm using d half v
squared or DX because they're half bear
and a half bear and then just calm down
okay so let's just remember why did I
choose this path in the first place what
can I do with this based on Logan okay
initial condition X equals four and then
allow me to evaluate what this constant
is ok so when I say initially x equals 4
i'm going to substitute if t equals 0
and X of a X and ay so I actually take
is for so I'm going to get in other
words negative a quarter toes tan
inverse are four or 4 plus this constant
that I don't know yet that's equal zero
because time is the subject of this
particular equation ok so tan inverse of
1 is is PI at four so this is negative a
quarter times pi over 4 so that gives me
the value of like the first constant
you're happy with that yep looking good
ok so let's just tied it up and say okay
my time equation for the displacement of
the first particle is going to be
negative quarter tan inverse survey on 4
plus the constant I just fed up happy
touch now let's have a look at this
having gotten this some time
displacement equation I now want to
return back cuz like I sort of like
gotten to the end of like a moment and
now I need to choose a new direction I
need to come back to this question and
say well now why is this useful to me
what am I going to do with it what are
we going to do with it yeah ma
fantastic okay so calling back your mind
to the car in the truck yesterday right
in order to work out that cars
acceleration to catch up to the truck
what I mean to know is well how long
does it have to catch up to the truck
how long is it gonna take to get to that
overtaking Lane that depending on how
long the truck took to get to the
overtake you later I want them to be the
same amount of time that's exactly
what's happening here so if I were this
guy to get to the origin at the same
time as this guy i'm going to use this
equation to find when X of a is equal to
0 that's when the first planet equal a
hits the archer ok tell me I'm gonna
write that ok particle a reaches origin
when x equals 0 ok and this is going to
give me a creature that I can solve for
to ie ok I'll put this over here on the
left-hand side so i've got negative a
corner 10 inverse of 0 which I think we
don't that is plus PI on 16 that's equal
to time but of course 10 investors area
is 0 so therefore now I've got a time so
this is how long the first particles are
going to take this is how long it's
going to take to get there so that's how
long be has gone it's going to get that
exactly the same over ok